all right what's going on guys this is
rob and episode number six of wanda
vision
was really really really really cool i
think it still leaves a lot of mysteries
with regards to
what's going on with evan peters
quicksilver by all standards of
measurement he
is definitively the quicksilver from the
mcu who was previously played by aaron
taylor johnson i mean in all reality as
you know the more i thought about that
the more it didn't really seem that
outside the realm of possibility
for him to be the new quicksilver i mean
think about it like sony had toby
mcguire as spider-man for like three
movies and then when they rebooted
they recasted him and then the mcu got
spider-man then they got tom holland so
it's not really outside the realm of
possibility for them to be like quick
slivers back in the marvel cinematic
universe but this time he's played by
evan peters
done and then we just roll with it right
we always have whenever the same
superheroes recast and played by
somebody else so not really outside the
realm of possibility what i do want to
talk about here in this video though
is the origin of agnes right i want to
talk about this for a second because
this i think is a really cool concept so
let's build on the discussion that we
had in the last video
where we talk about the idea that like
mephisto and and nightmare are one in
the same person
and they're basically the ones
manipulating wanda now what we know in
episode number six
is that in the previous lines that we
heard in like the the previews and
and so on and so forth the tv spots and
whatnot is that agnes said something
about the avengers and are you here to
save us this gives us a lot more context
in the sense that she was speaking that
directly to vision and she's absolutely
terrified right i mean
it's obvious that she doesn't have the
power to stop wanda even if she really
is agatha harkness and she is somebody
who can manipulate
sorcery and magic and different things
like that wanda's powers are just too
far beyond her ability to stop or
even remotely contain in any form or
fashion and so because that once she set
back to normal i started thinking and i
was like all right so let's build on
this idea of of mephisto
and this only real evidence anybody has
when you had dottie say the devil's in
the details and agnes said that's not
the only place he is and like the fact
that her husband's missing so agnes
always says that the anniversary between
herself and
ralph was june 5th and so if we tie this
into the idea of the salem witch trials
which
most everybody's doing at this point in
time then we can say with the salem
witch trials beginning back in 1692 that
agnes was potentially one of the first
people to be put on trial or to be
seized by the crazy folks at the time
and ultimately condemned to death
because of practicing witchcraft now
let's say she was never an actual witch
right she was just a woman who was in
the wrong place at the wrong time like
in episode number six where she said
that she went down
that she basically got turned around
went down the wrong street and then of
course they ended up grabbing her
snatching her up and that was the end of
that now while they have her tied to the
stake they're getting ready to set her
on fire that she's just kind of like no
no you know
somebody saved me please she cries out
for help and as we've kind of talked
about in the past
that like everything freezes and stops
and she's just kind of like what the
hell is going on right even the pain of
the fire goes away and she's met by the
arrival of mephisto
nightmare who says like you know what
are you willing to give or or you know i
can save you or whatever it is and she
never really considers the the
consequences of what she's doing she
literally just
makes a deal with the devil who turns
her into a witch and she in turn frees
herself but that's the quote-unquote
anniversary that she's talking about
which is when she first became not
really a servant but somebody who was
eternally bound to mephisto
nightmare in sense that when she dies
her immortal soul will actually end up
going to the realm of mephisto now let's
let's say that that's the origin of her
the question is how does that tie into
the events that are going on right now
why would this lead to like mephisto
nightmare you know those guys kind of
going forward and seizing wanda and that
kind of a thing
so one of the things we talked about in
the previous video is that whenever we
talk about the concept of mephisto and
nightmare in the marvel cinematic
universe we talk about them as if
there's something new
as if they somehow just came into
existence or something along those lines
and we pointed out the possibility that
maybe they've always been there
and this is actually given a little bit
of credence by way of the ancient one in
doctor strange because one of the things
that the ancient one tells steven
strange when he's learning to become
sorcerer supreme and things like that
especially after she dies
is that she had used the time stone on
multiple occasions
to find out what major threats were
going to be facing the earth or even the
universe and then stop those threats
before they ever became a major crisis
that's how doctor strange came up with
the idea to use that same tactic and
looking at any one of the 14 million
possible futures
where like thanos ultimately wins and
fighting the only one where the avengers
come out on top which of course leads to
iron man sacrificing his life and so if
we say that's the case and the ancient
one discovered
nightmare slash mephisto as a credible
threat out there and that at some point
in the future something was going to
happen it didn't have anything to do
with wanda but something was going to
happen and she ultimately ended up
locking them away then it would make
sense that if those spells and
incantations were placed there by the
ancient one
then when she died all those different
spells suddenly vanished now we could
also look at that and say okay maybe
during this time period
between the end of doctor strange one
and like the beginning
of avengers infinity war when stephen
strange was just doing his own thing
doing whatever he was doing in between
those movies that following the ancient
one's death that he used his power to
make sure those spells would continue on
and that mephisto slash nightmare and
whatever other threats exist out there
in the multiverse of the universe would
continue to be locked away but
when dr strange was dusted by thanos
those spells and things were gone and
maybe this was something that stephen
strange knew was going to happen but it
was kind of like
hey like maybe these are threats that i
can deal with at a later point in time
never considering the possibility that
they would bond themselves to wanda
because in his mind wanda from what he'd
seen and and really had no reason to
investigate what other powers she may
have that she was able to manipulate the
minds of others and she was able to use
telekinesis and that was it there was
never any indication that she had the
ability to alter reality on any measure
of a scale and so if there was a concern
that mephisto
nightmare were going to escape the
doctor strange could basically just lock
them back
up again but the problem that we're
gonna run into is that now that they
have escaped or now that he's escaped
basically mephisto slash nightmare
whatever he's bonded to wanda and
because her power is so extreme
albeit no one knew it at the time this
suddenly it's gonna be a credible threat
that steven strange can't cope with on
its own
now how this ties into the events of
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
i don't really know but i think that
book ends pretty well
in the theory that we had last video
where we talked about the idea of
everything that was going on with wanda
and nightmare slash mephisto and
explaining the nature of those guys and
why they would want wanda in the first
place the kind of white phoenix or the
crown effect different things like that
but i think it works but as always with
these theories guys make sure you punch
holes in them but if you guys want to
know more about the theory that we had
in the last video about everything that
we just talked about make sure you check
the end screen here and if you guys are
interested in learning more about the
character of mephisto make sure you
check the other end screen that will
send you to comics explained where i
have a video on the character that'll
make you an expert
in about 22 minutes but that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace